le 7 novembre 2016
un grand jour pour Montréal st.  Les
ministres et dignitaires de l'hôpital Justine
célèbrent l'ouverture de son tout nouveau
centre de recherche ils ne paient pas
modèle unique OCO voir à voir à Neuville Fashion
Fair en nouvelle façade 8 le bâtiment lumineux et
moderne se trouve dans l'aile ouest de
l'hôpital des enfants mais dans  l'
aile est
une crise se déroule depuis cinq jours les
inspecteurs saisissent des dossiers
fouillent les ordinateurs et interrogent les
employés du pavillon shall bruno un
établissement réservé aux enfants qui luttent
contre le cancer les inspecteurs sont de Santé
Canada l'agence fédérale vient de
recevoir une plainte anonyme contre
Dec Jen  un essai clinique de médicament pour les
enfants atteints d'un cancer en phase terminale la
réputation de l'un des meilleurs
hôpitaux pédiatriques du Canada est en danger
[Musique]
au moment où les inspecteurs arrivent l'
étude est déjà en difficulté
un enfant a abandonné en raison d'effets
secondaires quatre autres sont décédés et le dernier
des six enfants mourront alors que les
enquêteurs travaillent quelques semaines
plus tard vient la sanction  Santé Canada
suspend l'essai clinique de décision
Santé Canada estime qu'il n'est pas approprié
de poursuivre la phase un de l'étude
des effets secondaires graves et indésirables et des
décès sont survenus au cours du premier
cycle de dosage en outre, il n'a pas été démontré
qu'une dose sûre a été utilisée
Santé Canada documente 76 violations  de
la Loi sur les aliments et drogues, dont 23
violations critiques qui présentent un
danger pour les sujets des essais ou un
risque indu pour leurs droits, leur santé et
leur sécurité, c'est ainsi - non juste un
problème tout bon
sanaya la liste est très longue des
effets secondaires graves et un  décès qui n'ont pas été
signalés à santé canada dossiers
médicaux mis à jour personnel
insuffisamment formé et médicaments
périmés cela indique une très mauvaise surveillance
très mauvaise surveillance Jonathan Finley est
chef du département de neuro-oncologie
du plus grand hôpital pédiatrique de  les
États-Unis étaient en quelque sorte de la santé de leur
droit de fermer l'étude oh oui
absolument parce qu'il y avait à  o de nombreuses
violations et ils étaient tout à fait
appropriés pour l'arrêter, cela
aurait été une erreur s'ils ne l'avaient pas fait, mais
suspendre une étude clinique est une
décision très rare Santé Canada ne l'a fait que
cinq fois depuis 2012 cinq fois en 337
inspections Rainn Williams Jones  est
responsable du programme de bioéthique à l'
université les écoles de santé publique de maurya se
moquent de la documentation pour
CV leur déclaration un problème de dire un problème aussi
problématique Pâques Chanel chérie sortant de la
NFL notre première évaluation de Santé Canada
dresse le portrait d'un
essai de médicament désorganisé et incomplet en  un monde où
les soins de précision et le respect des
normes scientifiques sont valorisés avant tout daaaaisy
clinique adaptée à ceci est une clinique sur la
douce pizza Lorraine Oh Shaq date I un
document un SCV un gardien pour la foire de l'érable
CV de pesca seulement danse et camp situationnel à
travers van al  séparément d'Alex,
c'est exactement ce dont le personnel du
centre de recherche s'est plaint dans la lettre aux
ressources humaines de l'hôpital.  es
département envoyé huit mois avant
l'inspection de Santé Canada, ils
nous demandent d'ignorer le protocole et les
incidents qui se produisent pendant l'
étude des gents de pont qui devraient être signalés à
Santé Canada ne sont pas signalés, ce
qui soulève la question de la responsabilité de l'
hôpital.
Sanjay Singh avait de grands espoirs  pour l'
étude qui a été présentée comme la première
du genre au monde,
douze patients ont commencé,
puis 12 autres plus tard d'autres hôpitaux
pour la première fois st.  Les experts en oncologie de Justin
devaient concevoir et mener leur
propre étude clinique au lieu d'une étude choisie
par une grande société pharmaceutique, notre
première étude interne et aussi notre première
suspension pour un signe que les équipes de recherche de Justine
deviennent un phénomène, nous ne sommes pas
des boursiers du projet.  Je n'ai pas connu de
psychiques de choc toxique de conformité au
Cameroun. Le
but des études de deck Jen était d'examiner
les effets de la combinaison d'un
médicament de chimiothérapie que la ville avait avec du genestein, un
sous-produit de soja, une combinaison qui
, selon les chercheurs, donnerait un espoir
de survie et de rétablissement aux jeunes.
les patients atteints de cancer ma famine à 1 million
sont à la fois pharmaciens et parents de
trois enfants
Liam alien et Lina ont reçu un diagnostic de
cancer du cerveau à seulement neuf ans pour le
succéder 11 Lucas M Thomas le sien
de votre incitation Ivanka a parfois
répété un peu d'avantage un
abaisse-langue un  cicatrice dans notre jeu Matsuri
Nevada City était plus grave de manière
palliative c'est quand st.  votre péché a parlé à
la famille de l'étude Dec Jen Lena
serait la première patiente à signer
les parents d'Elena savaient que leur
fille ne vaincra pas le cancer mais ils ont
accepté de participer seulement j'ai fait un
concept les dates où Wiscasset était terminé dans
le pot je  je ne suis pas simplement dit ma mais
ça va couper les mères viennent d'un
amour dur près de leur travail alors que les pharmaciens les ont
poussés à poser aux chercheurs plus de
questions sur l'opposition comme ça vous savez
venir déterminer comme ceux Polina
Smerch Inka la réponse napot
content un rhume  mers mais cette question sur
la dose était très importante comme vous le
verrez plus tard Tuan et sa femme savaient tous les deux que
leur fille avait peu de chances de
survie mais comme tous les parents savaient
espero Amira Recep exactement la même chose pas vite
le miracle ne s'est pas matérialisé Linna
meurt de  cancer 27 jours après son premier
traitement ne se sent pas un peu ce
sentiment que je vis dans le CNBC et ça pourrait
apparaître ici à ce moment-là je pense que c'est leur
week-end je ne peux pas aller excusez-moi de dire
que c'était le 2 décembre  2015, ils ont quitté l'
hôpital et n'ont plus entendu
parler de la décision ou des
produits de ses chercheurs, comment avez-vous découvert que l'
étude avait été suspendue par des scientifiques de Santé Canada
qui ne vous ont jamais dit que l'étude
avait été interrompue, c'est nous qui leur avons dit
ce que les parents lenez aussi  ne savait pas, c'est
que leur fille avait reçu une dose de
médicament de chimiothérapie qui avait expiré un
manquement au protocole répertorié trois fois dans
les rapports de Santé Canada suspendant l'
étude lenez dossiers médicaux révèle également
un autre fait le médecin responsable de
l'étude a ordonné la perfusion du
médicament  de continuer même s'il savait que
le médicament avait expiré avant la fin du voyage,
Segarra a déclaré que si la
police de la mode avait la capacité de rencontrer la caméra,
nous avons parlé avec un oncologue que
Cengiz a traité plusieurs des jeunes
patients impliqués dans l'étude, nous avons convenu
d'avoir un  l'acteur recréer ce que le
médecin nous a dit parce qu'il
s'inquiétait des effets négatifs sur son travail
je veux dire skunk dans la baignoire
tuant m  e souper assez devise ne
tient pas compte de l'alias co-op SEO dr.
Michelle Val dirige les hôpitaux du
département d'oncologie métrologie il ne
voit pas le problème sérieusement la
communauté des soins la plus connue la vraie
texture toute la perfusion amusante si ce n'est
que quelques minutes vous pensez que c'est
acceptable nous supposons que CAC une
différence communautaire donc venkat merveilleux  position
si j'ai toujours une toxicité Lina n'a subi
aucun effet secondaire nocif mais peu importe
ses parents savent que les résultats scientifiques
de cette étude sont mis en doute un jour de plus
n'est pas une politique sur l'Amérique pop le
respect téléportail colas mamala le
résident une amende et  les tuteurs faciles Pascal
permettent qu'ils l'aient pointée, nous sommes semblables
à ils ont tout à fait raison car cela
remet en question la validité de tout
résultat, qu'il soit négatif
ou positif, nécessaire ou
nécessaire, a fait de nouveaux euros BFF une
ville pauvre en nutriments
vous
23 novembre 2016
deux  semaines après la suspension de l'
étude clinique devant une foule de
médecins à st.  Hôpital Racine dr.  Erica
Beaton Cove explique ce qu'il veut
accomplir avec la technologie Jen la ville pour dire
à Villa que les informations EDR pour non toxique une
partie productrice au testé dosé sur
le pâturage ont un indice semi ce que dr.
beaton cool ne le dit pas à ses collègues,
c'est que son essai clinique vient d'être
suspendu,
il dit que l'étude est en cours
.  Justine
hospital les deux mêmes molécules ont été
testées sur des souris en 2008 puis sur des humains à
l'hôpital adulte not Haddam en 2015 l'
équipe de st.  Justin a fait valoir que l'essai pour adultes a
produit des données encourageantes une
conclusion surprenante selon l'un
des chercheurs de not Adam qui a
accepté de nous parler de manière anonyme Je
n'ai pas trouvé que c'était une combinaison très efficace
si vous regardez profondément il y
avait quelques patients qui en ont vu
amélioration mais cliniquement ce n'était pas
très intéressant sur la base des résultats de
cet essai adulte les chercheurs ont soumis
leur protocole pour l'étude pédiatrique
à Santé Canada le protocole est comme
la Bible d'une étude clinique
comment caractériseriez-vous ce protocole
mal écrit superficiellement Redmond
superficiellement documenté  en termes de
contexte, ils auraient pu faire un bien
meilleur travail, même s'il critique
le manque de raisonnement scientifique clair
dans le protocole, le chercheur Jonathan
Finley pense que la combinaison
du citoyen et du genestein valait la peine d'être
examinée.
pour que l'idée de
regarder les deux médicaments ensemble,
cela semblait être un cu  l'idée quel est l'
objectif réel d'un essai expérimental sur le cancer
ce que les chercheurs appellent une
étude de phase un mille phaseurs sur un
esker composé de cèdre le milieu est converti en
un nouvel ensemble toxique mais ils sont très excréments sur
notre place ouverte en ce moment à propos d'une
intervention séparée expérimentale  les téléviseurs développent une
diaconesse sur les avantages de la peau de requin lors de la
rénovation, ce n'est pas exactement ce que
disent les chercheurs dans une lettre envoyée au
directeur du département, les études de la première
phase peuvent aider à la survie des
patients participants dans près de 10% des
cas dix pour cent c'est le
signe de pourcentage que Justine colle  dans les
publications scientifiques que l'hôpital
nous a fournies, mais ces 10% laissent nos
experts perplexes, en particulier jonathan
Kimmelman, il est l'un des plus
grands experts mondiaux de l'éthique
entourant les essais expérimentaux de médicaments contre le cancer.
Je ne sais pas où ils ont obtenu ce
chiffre. Je n'ai jamais  vu des membres comme ça,
je ne sais même pas comment vous pourriez quantifier
cela parce que généralement les survies ne sont même pas
mesurées je  d'une manière qui est fiable dans
les études de phase un, donc ce n'est certainement
pas cohérent avec les chiffres que
j'ai vus d'après ce que vous savez qui est
faux, je n'ai aucune base pour penser
que c'est vrai ce qui se passe lorsqu'un
chercheur propose une étude clinique à un
patient désespéré ou  leurs parents quels
mots sont utilisés quel espoir est allumé
cette famille tirera le rideau
sur le pont Jen étudie Jennifer MMC se
couche encore
et plus trakula ils sont des composites
Avella un flash holic bénisse ou moi-même
oui monsieur les hommes assistent à Andrews
probablement parce que Jennifer savait  il devait
arriver qu'elle avait déjà subi cinq
cycles de chimio et une greffe de moelle
osseuse pour traiter deux formes différentes
de leucémie lorsque l'Hôpital de Montréal pour enfants a
référé Jennifer à st.  Justine
son père mère frère et sœur l'
accompagnent reste calme Rama écoute la
chanson hawaïenne de Keith le pas sur la bataille
comme ils le font avec toutes les consultations médicales importantes
la famille enregistre la
présentation du médecin c'est beaucoup plus facile
que de prendre des notes
[Musique]
c'est dr.  Alhassan song l'un des
chercheur qui parle à la famille c'est
une étude clinique de phase 1 il dit plusieurs
fois qu'il devrait en théorie présenter l'
étude objectivement le but premier n'est
pas de guérir le patient saviez vous ce
qu'était une étude de phase 1 que c'est
expérimental  protéger sur une
publicité fossa prima sequent et Prosecco nutella
pour cette fossa étape une étape claire
se produit tue l'autre entreprise mais il y
avait un mot que tout le monde comprenait un
mot qui a captivé l'imagination
de toute la famille laissez-moi vendre mon c'est
Palmas attesa Lamacq il est  nourri sait un
bien commun qu'il fait qui satisfait la
clinique neuf fois c'est le nombre d'
occasions que le chercheur prononce le mot
rémission lors de la
deuxième ou de la troisième réunion et tant
que vous devez être en rémission, nous pouvons
donner jusqu'à 12 cycles il  mentionne jusqu'à
12 cycles de chimio même si les autres
patients ne pouvaient en supporter qu'un ou deux,
mais la famille de Jennifer ne le savait pas et
ne saurait jamais tout  ils
pouvaient penser à la possibilité que
son cancer entre en rémission, son
frère Michael, cela signifiait en fait
tout parce que s'il n'y avait aucune
chance de rémission, je ne l'aurais pas
glacé pour suivre cette voie,
il y avait d'autres essais de traitements là-
bas  et nous aurions opté pour ces
autres options. L'éthicien Brynn Williams
Jones a examiné la transcription complète de
la discussion entre le médecin et
la famille de Jennifer, vous demandez si quelqu'un
continuerait à évoquer la possibilité d'une
rémission dans un essai expérimental, c'est
chargé.
bien que seulement le laisser adapté à la situation
était laïc Jones émotionnel mon vénérable
le manipulateur de tipet de la langue d'origine
agrandir la douleur [ __ ] arraylist
un tel total mon ange élaborer une
description condensée jusqu'aux limites d'un voyage
facile c'est une équipe était le
Damas de la Commission Kosovar un lépreux III  protégé,
le chercheur dit à Jennifer qu'il est
peu probable qu'elle aille mieux et il
suggère  elle prend quelques jours pour y
penser c'est ce qu'elle dit qu'elle
veut faire mais seulement quelques minutes plus tard d'accord
mais je peux vous donner quelques idées que vous pourriez
prendre comme sept ans DePalma peut-être que cela peut
être fait cette semaine ou vous pouvez attendre  jusqu'à
la semaine prochaine c'est une urgence sur une
clé d'intervention numérique épuisée
il est sur Parker client senior il est sur
Parker dc-dc ne préfère pas être
inadmissible un an ou un cours GED elle
avunculaire péché l'
oppression sociale consommée de Clary ng ouais méga
problème dr  .  Yvonne a vu refuser d'être
interviewée pour ce rapport au lieu de cela l'
hôpital a offert aux personnes
le biochimiste qui a aidé à diriger l'étude
deux de ses supérieurs et le président
du comité d'éthique de l'hôpital nous
voulions leur point de vue sur la possibilité d'
une rémission une certaine émotion a facilement
fait don de ce  façon Alexa danila donc j'essaie
certains plus sur l'universel spécial une
omission de dîner de possibilité de vanille à
son propre crédit FL un véhicule un département
possible un compromis jeune jeezy quoi -
yo Kinshasa servant la subvention Cobra plus
parmi
un palma de sauver raymond une
commission latino a dit la  L'alternative de Papa saia
mais selon le professeur Williams
Jones, voici à quoi devrait ressembler un entretien de consentement,
nous ne savons pas si cela
aide et même si cela aide, nous ne savons pas
si cela vaut les effets secondaires que vous
pourriez potentiellement avoir pour la molarité
nausées fatigue fièvre diminution du nombre de numérations
, puis moins probable battements cardiaques rapides
vision floue douleurs dans les yeux et dans
l'abdomen  Dans ce
documentaire sur le cancer de PBS, un chercheur énumère en
détail tous les effets secondaires que l'enfant
pourrait ressentir dans un essai clinique proposé.
laisser da émettre du potassium c'est
probablement la décision la plus
difficile à prendre pour Jennifer - plus
de trois semaines après la rencontre avec
le st.  Jude Steen chercheuse elle signe
le formulaire de consentement et devient la quatrième
patiente à rejoindre le pont Jen Jennifer a vraiment
hésité avant d'accepter de rejoindre l'
essai clinique son dossier médical montre
à quel point elle a demandé plus de temps
deux fois tellement inquiète de l'effet d'un
sixième tour  de chimio aurait
finalement sur elle le 26 mai Jennifer reçoit sa
première dose de la ville Ben
elle avait été fatiguée et fiévreuse pendant une
semaine entière avant cela mais ses parents avaient
toujours espoir sur les positifs ou converser
ou t-butanol au violet
Wobbuffet -  s'est passé tout au long de la
saison
ouais le jour où beaucoup d'ammoniac ils ont joué
plus il y a une chance que nous le prenions
exactement bazooka de Familia Venise
assez loin dansad rollie pollie famiiy
nous a envoyé le sénateur Boozman monsieur
un oncologue de saint justine qui a traité
jennifer plusieurs fois a accepté de
parler  Nous anonymement nous avons demandé à un acteur de
répéter ce qu'il nous a dit quand on lui a dit
international Amati un peu grave son
infection rénale présentement ecause Assefa
quoi lo  le temps d'application du TOEFL est
fait en costume main.c technique moine
réitéré concernant jennifer est la
première patiente atteinte de leucémie à rejoindre l'
essai de médicament et elle devient également la
première à obtenir une dose réduite pourquoi parce que
la décision a provoqué trop d'effets
secondaires dans le  les trois premiers enfants,
tous atteints de tumeurs cérébrales, les chercheurs
connaissaient depuis un certain temps les
problèmes de toxicité des médicaments, c'est
parce que les patients adultes qui ont essayé le
médicament pour la première fois ont subi des effets graves cet
essai a utilisé une dose de 120 milligrammes que les
premiers enfants patients ont reçu trois
fois  ce montant 360 milligrammes l'
oncologue Jonathan Finlay ne comprend
pas non parce que la section de fond était
superficielle et mal assemblée
vous ne connaissez pas le raisonnement scientifique en
lisant le document le
raisonnement scientifique pourquoi tripler la dose selon
les experts en pharmacologie ont été consultés
les enfants patients  aurait dû recevoir
une dose similaire à celle déjà
documentée comme toxique chez l'adulte  essai
parce que la combinaison de médicaments n'a jamais
été testée sur des enfants, l'écriture dit que
la psyché des enfants de montreuil
augmente équitablement une diffusion plus large de la
caméra Sumida jusqu'à des actifs énergétiques presque nouveaux
jusqu'à tripler la dose ce que la
dose la plus élevée a été approuvée par l'
hôpital  comité scientifique presque
j'ai en fait pris cet
événement de sécurité post UT avec annulé vous
n'étiez pas inquiet pour les stocks de drogue
la ville un savoir confiant quand les mêmes
chercheurs ont admis avant que la dose ne soit
trop élevée dans une lettre à leur bus nous
pensons que ceux  les combinaisons à utiliser à l'
avenir devraient être inférieures à
celles choisies initialement compte tenu de la forte
probabilité que la toxicité médicamenteuse
Jennifer ne reçoive qu'une seule dose de la ville si
son état s'est détérioré rapidement et à la
mi-juin, elle a reçu un diagnostic d'
infection fongique peut-être liée à la drogue
un de ses médecins s'en souvient bien
infection tortue contrôle civil de
champignon
médecin si efficace chez semi papa  sont
à ce sujet, ne dites pas que nous croyons que les
extraterrestres étaient très inquiets, marchez
complètement, maman chanceuse, jennifer a contracté une
infection fongique très rare appelée geo
tricking, mais ce qui n'est pas rare du tout, c'est
le risque qu'une personne dans son
état développe une infection mortelle 39%
selon le protocole d'étude lorsque le dr.
Samsung a rencontré Jennifer quelques semaines plus tôt,
il a mentionné le risque élevé d'infection
mais n'a donné aucun détail s Cassell
pensez-vous que le fait de savoir que cela vous aurait
changé d'avis
une envie sûre sur un scooter rouge Vivek
doux tandis que sqc
risque à travers tout droit Papa Presidio comme
comparé pas l'odeur requise
dans les aliments mange la nourriture savoir
Casca c ou c ne représente qu'un choc le
choc les a frappés moins d'un mois après que
Jennifer a rejoint l'essai sur le médicament elle est décédée
le 23 juin 2016 d'une insuffisance respiratoire
aiguë et de complications de son
cancer sa famille qui  on lui avait dit qu'elle
recevrait le médicament de chimio jusqu'à
12 mois a été perdu
non Donna teto ou Stella premium veux être
présent avec le CD différent frais un
vaisseau spatial d'attaque Charlie Percy reste
calme reste calme un Cosmo
Jennifer et sa famille avaient passé des années à
élever  de l'argent pour lutter contre le cancer
soixante-quinze mille dollars qu'ils
croyaient en la recherche sur le cancer ils le font toujours
c'est juste parfait tezcan sur une cascade
Jennifer sur un ensemble de lys  sur la saleté en savoir
plus solitaire jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait une pauvre bosse de Purdy
ou quelle que soit l'information du maire corpulent
futur moi un photon iran-contra ilysme un
concours relaie avec moi
Gaskins important sécurisé du
combattant déco PI dont yone déco vélo sur
Coney
sash fin septembre  2016
trois mois après la mort de Jennifer, 5
ans, guillaume de Hesh est sur le point de
devenir le prochain patient un peu plus depuis
que vous a-t-on dit sur les
patients précédents une pop une fuite docpath
ère Angelababy sur Jersey City l'expert Martin peut
s'éloigner d'une personne politique
La mère de Young  aurait dit oui à
n'importe quoi n'importe quelle étude n'importe quel traitement
n'importe quoi qui pourrait peut-être la
même personne même s'il y avait un
pour cent de chance que cela aiderait était aussi un
joyau, ça s'est passé au plus, rendons-le
un peu fou même parle comme
ça  le parent du PDG vous avez un 10-1
dites les nouvelles incroyables sur ce qui est excitant
laissez-moi donner un Akua Villa Tosca plus nous
disons simplement que vous n'avez pas préparé les Français
alors qu'est-ce que vous saviez  w cetera cetera
votre femme était enthousiaste comment vous
sentez-vous alors était-ce donc nous tirons cet
enquêteur - vous ne vouliez pas que votre
fils soit considéré comme un ci-dessus qui fonctionne
jusqu'à ce que vous lui recommandiez un aquarium gelé
comme chaque parent  la mère
et le père de yeom ont signé le
formulaire de consentement écrit, il énumère chaque étape de l'essai,
les avantages attendus et les risques
jusqu'à un langage incroyablement évasif
qui n'est qu'un des problèmes que les éthiciens
Jonathan Kimmelman voit dans le
document de 15 pages évalué pour nous, il le trouve
incroyable  que le formulaire de consentement
fait référence à un déclin possible de la
maladie au lieu de cela, le formulaire aurait dû
indiquer que si vous participez à l'étude, les
perspectives de guérison ou les perspectives de
prolongation de votre survie sont très très
éloignées, mais en contribuant, vous
pouvez contribuer à faire progresser notre compréhension
de votre maladie le formulaire de consentement ne
dit nulle part que les chances de survivre
au cancer sont extrêmement faibles les parents guillaume le
signent le sep  27 septembre 2016
oui ah merci celui que nous avons mis sous le robinet
le SAP magique connecté à n'importe quel sel Bay
avant le pont Jen Guillaume avait déjà
subi six cycles de chimio tous pour
contrôler une leucémie qui était hors de
contrôle ne reçoivent pas un personnel l'a dit
Tyler Cupidon  membre ce n'est pas une pépinière
car Kirk Edgar est tout au long de son propre dos
un nez dedans lui-même voir le nouveau
cimetière vo point bien il complète mon
contrôle sur la pasión rappelez-vous chaud je
ne mange pas certain que le très dig miam a
rejoint le pont étude de janvier  ses
reins ne fonctionnaient pas bien, c'était tellement grave que son
admission dans l'étude a été repoussée. Les
médecins lui ont de nouveau donné le
feu vert le 29 septembre, mais ce jour-là,
un autre problème est le niveau d'amylase, une
enzyme qui absorbe les graisses.
le
protocole des études mais apparemment pas assez élevé
pour inquiéter le docteur yeom a été admis
malgré ses résultats de laboratoire une erreur majeure
de la part de l'équipe de recherche dit
notre expert c'est là comme une
exigence d'étude  ent qu'une élévation de l'amylase n'est
pas autorisée et que vous devez respecter
cela s'il y est dit quelque chose, nous
ne sommes pas autorisés à dévier, qu'est-ce que cela
signifie que les patients n'auraient pas dû être
autorisés à participer à l'étude, mais Yom rejoint
l'étude qu'il était  le sixième et dernier
traitement du patient diems n'a duré que cinq jours
comme la plupart des autres patients qu'il a
dû retirer de l'essai tôt non
seulement sa leucémie était de retour, une autre menace se
cachait dans les carreaux de plafond
Nobunaga Songshan Chandra Levy llamo
modernisme charmant est votre plate-forme  pierre
parce que ma chanson sonne un peu c'est vraiment
seulement ça pour apprendre le plus basique donc
ça ne voulait pas jouer peu attention
elle fume
dire de prendre de la vitesse ou de la position de
Naomi Yoshida le gamin normal CCT aasman
chand en feu mais le système dans da Les
actes de coin le feront  le personnel de la supercellule de l'
hôpital scelle la porte de la salle de bain avec du
ruban adhésif et une serviette et propose de déplacer les jeunes
dans une autre chambre, mais c'est la
seule chambre familiale disponible, ils décident de  rester
quand vous avez signalé la moisissure dans le
plafond ont-ils bien dit que vous deviez
quitter la pièce parce que c'était dangereux un
gars coller des chaussettes si on me le demandait j'ai dit Dodger
oui non non papa fils kim hong-sik
séparer drupal le seul mouvement d'image qui
était en octobre  Le 7 puis le 10 est devenu
son point d'origine juste important de
déserter ces petits points rouges transformés en
croûtes et répartis sur tout le corps de Guillaume
il y a tous ceux aussi crié Marcia
c'est ton chat Anita do les avocats ont dit
on est à la maison disons que c'était sur Ana
Samedi à Dan Issel acronyme suis une 2e
erreur var jeune le taco de dinde dans un
calcul de marche donc c'est juste en supposant que la
banque de trésorerie voit des économistes pour la sauce pour pâtes
avec le sifflet de mise au point mais c'était
qu'une infection fongique très rare
Fusarium association concerne Fusarium
est AG  frais de champion D'Amato dr.  Mishon lavalliere a
passé 17 ans à diriger le service
des maladies infectieuses à l'
hôpital Mizzou Navajos mo nous lui avons demandé si ce
plafond aurait pu conduire à cette infection
savoie été sous sédation le brownie pré
dépendait uniquement du linge sale tu es une
assez question le kouzef un homme que nous voyons
quand  on sauve des cas c'était comme ça mais l'
hôpital n'a pas analysé la dalle du plafond
donc on ne saura jamais ce qui se
cachait là-haut n'aurait-il pas été logique
de tester
le temps pour savoir exactement ce que c'était
bonjour il vient m'accompagner vient au milieu
la graisse consommée qui est une fiction
transmet la mise en page des artistes de ballet
Sanderson dit que si notre analyse n'a
trouvé aucune trace du champignon en tant
qu'homme mécanique étant donné le stress malchanceux
potassium ah Dodger sien admettez-vous que
la situation était potentiellement dangereuse
enfermer un enfant très malade dans une pièce
avec des carreaux de plafond au sol dans la
salle de bain sous la glace je pensais oh mon
dieu ne touchez jamais champion la
position qui montre traiter même les
acres de fondation je  n hôpital dans une chambre
avec la salle de bain comme celle-ci, il y a un
enfant sans système immunitaire
prenant sa batte juste en dessous
Rosenthal avait été emmené sur l'aîné
LaShawn alors que tout le monde n'était pas sûr, mais le
docteur Nvidia est parfaitement clair, un
plafond de salle de bain comme celui-ci n'a pas sa place
dans  un cas de service de
leucémie de l'hôpital pour enfants en dollars de l'État dans
l'éducation spéciale, donc la ténacité d'Ivy
Ranallo par le biais du SPD c'est la
réponse de Paul Louis semaines, vous savez qu'il
développe c'est un film de fiction sur un
homme virtuel nommé fatale le public
dans lequel vous vivez il y a deux personne  cette
saga d'image Billy Duren chinnu terrible l'
infection a dévasté le corps de guillaume mais
jusqu'à récemment ses parents ne savaient pas
à quel point vous avez commandé une copie de ses
dossiers médicaux
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit pourriez-vous me dire est l'
obésité mesurée en libre c'est un
entraîneur calmement samake  c'est un indice pour certains
Yeol, donc c'était la sortie de l'infection d'
une vente à découvert
ce que non monsieur il y a un mr.  domestique bien
ne vous a pas dit sasame même pas entendu ou
vu à l'échelle cela fait près de deux ans
que le jeune est décédé et ses
parents regardent en arrière maintenant pour les
cinq assaillants aseptiques bâtards
merci la police mais finissez mr.  cuisiner
régulièrement, heureusement, sauf quand
vous dites osez vous pourriez dire pour elle que
c'était la dernière chance de récupérer son petit
dôme sa pirouette comme elle l'
appelait mais pour son père, le procès de Dec Jen
était un pas de trop
deuxième phonétique a sauver un  sécant sur
la panique de Josie c'est mon groupe de maman ou à
propos de l'appartement un problème jusqu'à ce que nous allions
disparition de la feuille
[Musique]
le procès de la décision a été suspendu après la
mort de guillaume mais cela ne s'est pas arrêté là
pendant une grande partie de 2017 Sanjay Singh s'est battu
dur pour amener Santé Canada à  inverser la
suspension c'est clair dans les
documents que nous avons obtenus en mars juin et
novembre
Santé Canada ordonne aux chercheurs d'
expliquer leurs erreurs et de changer leurs
méthodes ouais ça parait très étrange ça
parait très étrange et je ne connais
pas le fonctionnement de la Santé  Canada, vous
savez, s'il s'agissait d'une visite sur le site réglementée par la FDA, vous
savez qu'ils n'auraient
repris aucun de ceux que vous connaissez, messieurs,
vous savez qu'ils étaient juste vous fermés,
je pense qu'ils w  Le patient étant en effet très
patient deux ans après l'
inspection,
Santé Canada analysait encore les
informations envoyées par les experts que l'
hôpital a embauchés. L'agence affirme maintenant que le
cancer était la principale raison
du décès du patient et admet que des
effets secondaires tels que des infections fongiques ont été
indiqués dans le  protocole mais une question
demeure si l'équipe de recherche avait
signalé les effets secondaires
Santé Canada dit oui parce que les
infections étaient beaucoup trop courantes l'
agence maintient sa décision de suspendre
l'essai clinique
la passion d'avoir informé les parents
de ce qui s'est passé avec Dec gen Sakon
suppose  une attaque de chef d'orchestre par
effet fringant du manoir au zoo sécurisé au-
delà de toute raison pour Connor a enterré une
boîte Allosaurus les experts ont assailli un
assez drôle pour un exemple d'acier de table
qui à l'hôpital a négligé ses
fonctions de surveillance st.  Le comité d'éthique de Justin
est censé s'assurer que les
patients des essais de médicaments sont protégés, mais le
comité n'a même pas été informé des
problèmes avec Dec Jen au début une fois qu'il
a découvert que les médecins en charge de
l'essai étaient ceux qui avaient expliqué
la question alikum  à la sécurité sociale,
ceux-ci sont enfin positifs signifient une
période pendant laquelle tout va bien, contrairement à ce que
Santé Canada a trouvé exactement,
les meilleurs intérêts des patients sont
primordiaux dans un essai clinique, mais il en va de même
pour des données de recherche précises garantissant que
cela incomberait normalement à une
entreprise externe  mais en embaucher un était trop cher
pour st.  justine hospital puisque l'étude
n'était pas soutenue par une grande
société pharmaceutique qui surveillait alors les données
un employé de l'hôpital le véritable responsable
de l'essai de médicament inacceptable
selon le chercheur Jonathan Finlay vous avez besoin d'
une surveillance externe la recherche clinique
a changé elle est devenue appropriée
très très  beaucoup plus rigoureux qu'il
ne l'a jamais été, il faut donc se
demander si une institution qui n'a
pas l'expérience et l'expertise pour
mener un essai de phase un devrait
être dans le domaine de la réalisation d'essais de phase un à
moins qu'elle n'ait une surveillance intégrée,
selon l'hôpital  il
aimerait continuer à surveiller les futurs
essais de médicaments en interne mais pas par un
employé de l'équipe de recherche car pour le reste, l'
hôpital se sent incompris le cas du Japon
antic avait avoué de manière incomplète
parfois en particulier la section ik y
bokuden accord sur le laboratoire sous le
centre canada comte elisa connecte le
dévouement de  administratif
allez-vous redémarrer la procédure d'essai de la toxicomanie  esser
et agrandir le pavillon les besoins sont
ceci n'est pas un
esker philippin Jeremy amorphe nature
transport Baskar apprendre Nevada risque
Monsieur nom Lamont clarté les ratios
les avantages potentiels de la montagne
schéma Kellogg Allura se trouvent dans l'impératrice Malad
je suis Mona Lisa dit Pierre câliner Eddie
DCD  électricité possible ne
faites pas de mal d'abord assez exactement
[Musique]